we've got another one of these
membership sort of contest giveaway
things Eric got in touch and Eric is
sponsoring half of 20 memberships Eric
has already paid thirty dollars for each
of twenty memberships that are available
you can have those memberships by just
paying the other half which is another
$30 it is effectively a half-price
membership and you get to keep that
membership price for as long as you want
to now the way this works is very simple
you have to contact me it's going to be
first-come first-served you write to me
and then I will send you a code a
special code a secret code one might say
to the first 20 people that say David I
want one of those I want one of Eric's
memberships and then you can use it to
sign up the first 20 people and again
you can keep the discounted price for as
long as you want to remain a member a
lot of major things are happening if you
want to sponsor some memberships feel
free to get in touch we've had a bunch
of people sponsor memberships over the
last six months and it's been a really
big thing for us I mean dozens and
dozens of memberships now in some way
shape or form have been sponsored by
viewers and listeners if you want to
participate in this particular
membership special eric has already paid
for half of your membership you merely
make make a payment for the other half
get in touch david pakman.com click on
the contact button and then just send in
an email saying David I want one of
Eric's memberships and ask and you shall
be rewarded
assuming you're one of those first 20
people